bienvenido y explíquenos cuáles son las
principales denuncias que pudieron
recoger
gracias por invitarme hemos hablado con
afganos célebres que han sobrevivido a
violaciones en grupo ataques de grupos o
han sido perseguidos por sus propios
familiares que se unieron a los
talibanes y no te tienen esperanza que
nadie los proteja las historias que
hemos escuchado son desesperadas y
extremas de tristes es importante
comprender que si bien la canción ha
sido durante mucho tiempo un país
difícil para hacer el gp solía ser un
lugar donde pequeñas comunidades
conseguían existir viendo las personas
en el gp y tenían parejas trabajos y
amigos y hoy la mayoría de las personas
con las que hablé tienen miedo de salir
de sus habitaciones incluso para comprar
comida señor fever y cuáles serían los
mecanismos para llevar a los talibanes
ante la justicia porque ellos habían
dicho ante el mundo a respetar los
derechos humanos
sí pues cuando a deportados al talibán
dijo que el gobierno respetaría los
derechos humanos dijo específicamente
que es una teoría nuestro este respecto
de los derechos de las personas lgbt y
entonces para responder a su pregunta es
importante que la comunidad
internacional tenga claro que los
derechos lgtb son derechos humanos y son
tan fundamentales como los derechos de
las mujeres las minorías religiosas y
cualquier otro ser humano y el propósito
de esto que nos dice que cree que se
puede hacer para ayudar a la comunidad
lgtb más en afganistán
si es muy difícil muchos alcances del
evento que quiere irse y los países que
respetan los derechos del betis deben
hacer más para ayudarlos a ponerse a
salvo rápidamente pero no todas las
personas pueden irse o quieren irse del
país y las personas se repetirían
afganistán tienen el derecho de estar
seguras en su propio país la comunidad
internacional debe encontrar formas de
presionar a los talibanes para que
detengan la violencia y la violación de
los derechos de las personas lgbt y yo
sé que es difícil imaginar que los
talibanes cambien de opinión sobre este
tema pero eso no significa que la
comunidad internacional deba abandonar a
los afganos de betty y es cierto que en
el país los familiares de las personas
lgtb y deciden abandonarlos por temor a
represalias
sin más que abandonarlos en muchos casos
las familias son la principal fuente de
la violencia
escuchamos una historia de una mujer
cuyo tío la mató de blaquier y mató
después de
enterarse de que era lesbiana la forma
en que sus padres encontraron de
protegerla fue obligada a casarse con un
hombre y enviar a la nueva pareja a un
país extranjero y después uno de sus
primos contó que era lesbiana a su
marido y por eso ella ya no podía
escapar